[Music]
so
[Music]
this week on book notes our guest is
journalist and communications consultant
melba patillo beals
she'll discuss her recent book
warriors don't cry
a searing memoir of the battle to
integrate little rock's central high
[Music]
melba patillo beals
warriors don't cry where's that come
from grandmother said everybody's a
warrior on the battlefield for the lord
and she used to sing a song i'm on the
battlefield for my lord and so it comes
from from that from her singing
and also from the experience i had with
the 101st airborne the soldiers who were
warriors who came down to guard us when
i was going to school at central high
central high is where little rock
arkansas central high 1957 was the it
was like a major bastion of white
segregation in the south because it was
ranked among the top high schools in the
country
and uh it was where the elite children
of little rock attended school
and it was
one believes the last place they would
have wanted to have black children come
and in order to stay there get there be
there
president eisenhower indeed ultimately
had to send soldiers warriors what year
are we talking about 1957
september of 1957 we're really talking
about that whole period because you know
in 1954 brown
versus the board of education said
separate is not equal and thus began
this whole event of the south to to to
integrate and not integrate
and this whole almost warring like
environment or
atmosphere wherein
most white people said no we're not
going to agree we don't care what the
supreme court says and federal judges
said yes you will integrate and so then
everybody said well how can we do it
with as little
as possible how can we stingily
integrate and that's what they did in
little rock they stingingly agreed to
integrate
on the cover of your book is
an artist rendition of what
um
this is the normal rockwell rendition of
a small child being escorted to school
by sheriff southern sheriffs and it's
kind of i think meant by him to have
been
a generic
essence of what was going on at the time
a small black girl with these very tall
white sheriffs escorting them in school
is that you and the piece of art well
not really i was quite a bit taller than
that quite a bit older than that child
is there but i think the picture
reflects tells the story
it's certainly not a picture that that
that i in the beginning chose but as as
i've gotten accustomed to it i think it
immediately tells you what this book is
about it's about this child's struggle
to go to the school
unknowingly um to change
what was going on at the time the
traditions of the time set the scene for
us where were you in 1957
in 1957 september i had just come back
from heaven to me heaven was cincinnati
ohio i just had my first trip out of the
south
having realized that all my daydreams
were true that there was a place where i
could be free and i could breathe there
was a there was a place where black
folks ate in white folks restaurants and
there was a place where a man a white
man played music to make my meal go down
and so i was like flying high in august
of 1957. where had you gone to
cincinnati just to visit relatives just
as a happenstance
i had been embroiled or at least paying
a lot of attention to what was going on
reading the newspaper
constantly every day because 1952 i was
almost raped
just immediately after the brown versus
board of education decision had come
down and so i said i was going to read
the newspaper because i wanted to know
when white men got angry and sometimes i
had to spend my own nickel for it but so
i was very well aware that in little
rock arkansas the topic of the moment
was whether to integrate schools where
to integrate schools how to do it with
the least amount of black children
involved how old were you in 57
15.
and you went to what school before you
went to central high school horace mann
which was the all-black high school
there
a very small high school one story
we drove around oddly enough central
high school a lot because my mother was
getting her master's degree and it was
like she was doing at the university of
arkansas and that was kind of on a
pathway a sunday drive that we took past
this grandiose
uh seven or six story high
building like a castle four block square
something quite beyond my imagination i
couldn't even imagine what was in all
those rooms but i knew i wanted to see
it
and what was home like where did you
live in little rock and how many folks
do you live with 11 21 cross street i
lived with my grandmother
india annette payton who had been the
main center of my life all of my life my
mother lois patello was a teacher
she had gotten by that time her master's
degree herself integrating the
university of arkansas classes in order
to do so but very subtly so very quietly
so not a big row over it just talking
about it over the dinner table my little
brother conrad
uh lived with us he was then at the time
about nine i suppose 19 11 11
at the time
and that's all my parents at this point
were divorced my father visited on a
regular basis he was very hostile
towards my mother's decision to allow me
to go to central high school
by the way what are you doing here in
san francisco
i've been here since i was uh
60 17 years of age when i left central
high school i came to the north escaping
the clan
got off a plane was met in santa rosa by
about 15 white people
unknowingly and i went to live with a
white family dr mrs george mccabe who
still are mom and dad to me who still
live in uh they live up in occidental
california and they walked me over the
bridge to adulthood they
brought me back the sanity and the love
and the consciousness i needed to move
on to another space in my life and they
taught me the definition of equality not
by what was in the dictionary but by how
they treated me are you married divorced
have a daughter who is now uh living in
los angeles has graduated from ucla
and uh is working on her acting career
sometimes works for me in my public
relations business did you go to college
san francisco state university
uh columbia university for a graduate
degree in broadcast journalism and film
was an nbc newscaster worked for the
public broadcasting station here first
kqed on the
famous newsroom
where i cut my teeth on journalism with
some of these very seasoned ladies and
gentlemen and
i'm very pleased with that backdrop to
my life why this book now
took me a long time to cough it up
was very difficult to write very
difficult right
i always thought that one day someone
would walk in and there'd just be this
large brown puddle of tears and it would
be me you know it took therapy it took
focus it took prayer to get it up to
talk about it to remember it all
to
to be able
to talk about it from a neutral pedestal
i did not want to write the book
through any veil of hostility but just
to simply tell you my story
and let you decide what you think about
it how do you remember all this
kept a diary
i write things down incessantly i mean i
i hear snatches of conversation on a bus
or in a in a lobby so i always have kept
notes
scraps of paper or in this case a diary
i actually have a little pink diary with
a little white girl on it with a
ponytail which was one of my diaries
given to me my grandmother my
grandmother that locked because i used
to talk too much grandmother you know i
used to say things like uh
you know uh people
are like clothes on a coat hanger our
souls are the coat hanger and the
clothes can be interchanged we're not
our bodies we're ourselves grandmother
would say shh darling write that down
don't don't tell everything and so i was
very kind of psychic as a child
uh predicting one point of cousin's
death saying oh
i think uh deborah's gonna drown soon
grandma let's say don't talk about that
write that down and so that's how i
started writing things down because
people thought i was a little strange
so she would say write letters to god
or write it down because as early as
five i would say you know wait a minute
now what's going on here are the white
folks going to be in charge forever are
is it that we're going to be in charge
you know come june to december they're
in charge now i mean how did this whole
system get set up you say everything's
equal you say god loves us all well
grandma what's going on you know and
she'd say shh write a letter to god
so that hence the whole the the the
writing thing was an early thing in my
life
back in september of 1957 how were you
chosen to integrate uh central high
school simple thing two years before
in 1955 just after the brown versus the
board a teacher came through class black
class all black class and said which of
you lives near central high school and
would like to go i put my hand up i was
always a girl who would do anything once
and i was always curious about what was
inside that school so i merely put my
hand up and i went away you know i
didn't say anything
to my parents about it i just put my
hand up said yeah i'll go sign here
and it wasn't until august when we were
in cincinnati ohio of 1957 that news
came up
uh saying
that these people were going to go and
the big row about the whole thing and my
dad called my mom and said you know
they're talking about your kid and you
know
as my grandmother said all hades broke
loose
how many were there
originally there were 16.
but we dwindled to nine because people
got frightened because of threats of
violence uh the circumstance that
emerged as time went on
what's the first threat of violence you
can remember
just hearing people say we're gonna we
we're not we don't want these [ __ ] in
our school is hearing hearing that kind
of definitive statement and hearing what
they were willing to do the hearing-ness
of the mood was to me the first thing
that made the sight of my heart hurt
made my feelings sad
made me want to cry
the thought that someone would kill me
the threat of killing the actual
feeling of physical violence was the
first day we went to school i went with
my mom
and we were we were with uh we were
supposed to meet the other
eight
children
uh at a certain point and there were
some white ministers etc
and um we missed that point we came up
sort of behind a crowd that was directly
across the street in front of central
high school
and the whole crowd at this point was it
was like going to a football game you
know a big game when you hear all this
row or rodeo and we walked
up behind this crowd trying to figure
out what are they focusing at what are
they looking at they were looking across
the street and of course what they were
looking at was my little friend
elizabeth eckford walking the gauntlet
that famous picture that you see of her
walking up and down in front of those
troops trying to get
access to the sidewalk that would lead
her to the front door of central high
school
and we're watching her do this and we're
hearing the crowd yell and we're
watching what's going on it's like it's
like being on mars our minds can't
compute we've never seen anything like
this never felt anything like this never
been in this in this mob setting don't
know why the police standing around a
uniform don't police help please help
people don't they don't they stop
violence of course they do they're going
to help her any minute but they weren't
troops are troops the soldiers they have
guns why do they have guns why is she
walking up towards them and they're not
helping her
here's the dedication to your book
that you have in the front of the book
and you list
the others are they all alive today yes
very much some of them grandpas and
grandmas two of them as a result of this
incident elected to go abroad and have
never ever lived in this country money
gene brown and canada and gloria ray
calmark in the netherlands
they moved to those countries on purpose
absolutely i've never ever lived there
they have lived their whole adult lives
there married there had their children
there etc i've only seen them twice
still angry
painful not angry in pain and deep pain
i don't think either one of us we all
together actually president clinton then
billy clinton to us billy brought us
together in 1987 at the mansion the
mansion where governor farbers had set
and planned our demise
and
i don't think angry pain in pain and
deep pain
hurt
not not not
angry more now um
dealing with pain of it all
go back again to the beginning um
the the first day
so we are watching elizabeth walk this
gauntlet and all of a sudden the men
surrounding us say well wait a minute we
got us the [ __ ] right here and they're
saying to her [ __ ] go home [ __ ] go
back to where you belong what age
15
is elizabeth but the people around us
around her are adults
older some of them students but most of
them adults the people that are
surrounding us are adults some men in
suits some in overalls adult human
beings behaving the way i've been taught
no one behaves
screeching violent epitaphs you know
just really cursing uh but saying mostly
very ugly things
and at first your ear doesn't hear your
ear does not in your mind can't can't
make all this makes sense because you
know where are you what's happening
what's going on and then the people
nearest to us said just as we were
trying to figure out what are we live
about elizabeth should we go get her
what should we do a mother said i think
we do more harm by going across the
street
then
we thought well okay the police are
going to intervene but they didn't but
then the men around us started saying
hey we don't have to worry we've got a
[ __ ] right here who's president
at the time eisenhower eisenhower's
president and what's his attitude about
all this he doesn't know about this yet
because this is the first monday we went
and so so it's like the first big effort
in the south to integrate this at this
level
the first official pronounced decision
voted upon agreed upon supposedly in the
city effort this is how we're going to
do this why little rock
i think um
i have no idea why little rock to tell
you the truth but
part of what made this so big i believe
was governor falbas's defiance of
federal law do you ever meet him yeah
yeah when
um quite a bit
just after the incident
at a distance not you know just this is
the governor these are the nine kind of
things not
hello howard you look you in the eyeball
kind of thing
more seeing than meeting did you ever
ask any of the people back then why they
hated black so much
many times because they would say
you don't have a right to go to school
with our children
you're not good enough
we don't want you with our children you
stink you're stupid
uh
you know you can't go you had to wash
our dishes clean our kitchens you can't
go to school our children what was the
rest of the country doing at that point
how many people in cincinnati knew about
little rock then quite a few we were
getting letters
phone calls
uh it was beginning to be a national
news event
and again at the end of that year it
would be
voted the biggest one of the top 10 news
events of the year reporters by the
second time we went back to school our
omas coming to little rock just
thousands of reporters from around the
world all sorts of places and then our
lives now are in some ways being
dictated by these events around us after
that first time i tried to go to central
high school and then came home had to
come home had to escape for our lives or
to run away from the men who were
carrying the ropes to hang us
that was the first real time real
violence that somebody actually struck
me reached out at me held a rope up said
what they were going to do with it
so
why didn't they by the way
god prayer fate running running running
for my life my mother running my mother
throwing the keys at me and saying you
drive away leave me here my mother
swearing for the first time slapping me
in the face saying get out of here she
had just been teaching me to drive in
the grocery store and so uh just fake
god please god help me mom's still alive
my mother is 83 years of age still very
much alive just gave me a lecture this
morning
am i going to church on sunday uh let's
see the last letter i wrote her she
corrects in red and re-mails it back to
me
uh she's with the program listen ma
still driving her little red car to
church on sunday still teaching a sunday
school class where in little rock
arkansas my brother little conrad
was just appointed by the president as
the first black u.s marshal in history
of the south
conrad who was the first black trooper
the first
black trooper in the troopers that kept
us out of that school
time changes things
did your mother and brother read your
book
yes
what's what what do you remember them
reacting to
well my brother called me and he had
tears in his voice and he said you
really can write
you really can write and and and uh
i love you and i'm sorry what a good
book i couldn't put it down and my
mother see i always knew i had to write
a book that both my mother and where my
grandmother alive
would approve of and and and the process
of writing this book as you see it was
almost as difficult as attending central
high school the first publisher i had
was kind of a caretaker plantation owner
kind of guy
a southern uh former southerner who
wanted to take over the process and
wanted to direct in accordance with his
lens or his vision where it should go
and i said always it must be told
through the eyes of the child never
through the eyes of adult
who then puts the layers of judgment
over what happened i just wanted the
incidents to stand alone
un uncommented upon just this is what
happened
when was the first
when did you really get serious about
doing this book oh i was serious two
years after i left central high i was
serious during the time i was there i
was taking notes writing it down because
it was just too big for me to handle i
couldn't tell anybody everything that
was happening i couldn't tell my grandma
even everything that was happening i
could only tell god about it but we're
37 years later and but when in the
modern time did you get i have 12 drafts
of it 12. minimally 12 drafts 12
separately written drafts absolutely i
have boxes at home of of that book when
did you write the first one
when i was 19.
but before that even a kind of
collection of loose pages of it when was
the first time you took it to a
publisher
probably not until i was
37 36
and what was the first reaction
keep writing this is good you you yes
we're interested we want this do this
that or the other you've got to spill
the first time i sent this to an agent
my friend danielle steele who introduced
me to her agent and her name is phillip
we called her god and she was very
instrumental
phyllis was in helping me along this
pathway although she was not my agent
ultimately when it was published that
was sandra dykstra but
phyllis the first time i wrote this book
it was like 380 pages long and only 70
pages were about the actual incident and
so phyllis said you're not really you're
not really ready to spew the story yet
you must do some work and indeed i went
back into therapy
um dealt with it prayed about it just
just i had to live with this i had to
get this up it was like a
concrete in my gut
a solid
concrete bolt of pain in my gut that i
had to get up piece by piece what kind
of therapy
all kinds of therapy you know going to
the marin county kinds of guru groups
uh going to a therapist the whole the
whole thing
talking about it trying to get it up
trying to be able to say how i felt the
pain of it therapy of sitting with it
reading about it reading most of it done
personally in terms of reading about
okay what should this be like and then
therapy of writing about it just writing
over and over again
this is what happened writing down to
the core of of my feelings then allowing
them to come up for example one morning
i remember arising at five and crying
from five to twelve
and then being able to write
sitting in a room by myself spent a lot
of time by myself to write this book
almost a solid year by myself didn't
work didn't
support it by my daughter actually i
couldn't have done it without her
uh to to write the book so it was a long
time a lot of a lot of uh dealing with
myself in it a lot of going to school to
learn how to write to get the craft down
although i have a master's in broadcast
journalism there is a difference in the
languaging
and so this took a lot of my energy and
a lot of my time where did you write it
in san francisco right here right here
in tampa in your home in my home in
in a down ultimately the final draft was
written in just a downstairs room of my
home in sausalito
and then how did you
and finally how did this particular
publisher pocket books pocketbooks
decide to do this um i was having
difficulty with my first publisher
great difficulty and i wanted out
originally there had been a bid for the
manuscript it was a big thing in my life
it was now this thing is written it's
wonderful my agent sandra dykstra had
put it up for bid and several major
publishers bid on it one publisher got
it and then wanted was this southern
gentleman i told you about then wanted
to redirect it wanted to recarve it
wanted to say no i don't want it written
like this we like this idea i want you
to go back i want you to rate it from
the perspective of an adult and so we
battled for a year i had a stomachache
for a year because i was hell-bent
on writing it in the voice that i had
begun it in
finally
when that contract didn't work out
pocket books had been one of the earlier
bidders on the book
and my agent went back to pocketbooks
unfortunately i ran into an editor at
pocketbooks whose name was julie
rubinstein
who would become my angel and that she
never once said to me this is what i
want
this is what you have to do she would
say to me
consider this or do you really want this
or
so and so but she was to hold my hand
along my own path she did not
lead me to a separate path when did it
first get into the bookstores
may of this year
how's it doing very well
uh it will be condensed by reduced
digest in january it will become a youth
edition in january
uh disney is looking at it as a movie
and and what has been the reaction of
people that you talk to when you go
around have you traveled have you done
that i have yes i've done the tour
it's been enormously rewarding for me to
run into people who say
i couldn't put your book down or your
book has inspired me to do what i think
i couldn't do or i'm in a lot of pain
about this that one woman 70 years of
age called me up and said you know i
don't believe in god and i didn't
believe in prayer but i read this book
and now i pray every day and life is a
little better for me so those kinds of
things lots of black children saying you
know i've read this book and i thought
my life was hard but it was not hard
considering what you've been through i
think i'll do better
um so enormously rewarding most
everybody who's come to me or called me
or written to me and said i i got to do
better because you did better and that
makes me feel good lots of prisoners
lots of letters from prison
from people saying
you know ouch i thought that what
happened to me in my life justified my
doing what i've done
but you suffered so much more than i did
and you're not negative and so that that
has been really rewarding for me is that
people have gleaned the good in the book
the book i always wanted to be about the
resurrection not the crucifixion
back to 57
leading up to the day you went into
central high school i remember you
writing about
phone calls you would get at home
terrific phone calls all night uh my
grandmother would would spew bible
verses to the they call up and my
grandmother would say you know does your
mother hear you say this does your god
know you're speaking this way what would
they say we're going to bomb your house
who was calling white people who didn't
want me to go to school segregationists
by this time beginning to organize
beginning to get themselves together
beginning to have regular meetings
beginning to have regular rallies that
we heard about that were written about
in the paper
invitations to rallies appeared in the
paper white's premise rallies you know
rallies saying we don't want to this
integration we're going to get you
together we're going to keep this from
happening
one of my colleague clarida walls who
was going to school her that was they
found the bomb that went off underneath
her house so that we were now beginning
to experience some of the threats of
violence you know cast against us so we
knew they weren't kidding they uh they
were traveling the streets of little
rock beating up black people for no
reason so by now we we were i was
sequestered in my house couldn't go
anywhere i couldn't play records
couldn't go be with my friends couldn't
go to the community center couldn't do
anything i'd ever done before his link
link was a boy in school
uh who that is not his real name
i was recently offered by a major talk
show the end of the world if i were to
say his real name he he is from an
aristocratic southern family segregation
is family
um a white boy who crossed the line who
saved my life who helped me when i was
in school do you know where he was
yes
why did you not
name him
he is still a member of a aristocratic
southern segregationist family he has a
mother and a father and children and a
wife i don't have a right to to to name
him
and when was the first time you met him
in central high school he was student
senior
and um
just by accident i was standing outside
of the wrong side of the building see i
envisioned that this school one of the
things interesting i just went there
with a group of children from the magic
bus and one of the things that was
astonished astounding to them was
envision that this school is two blocks
long let me interrupt because those
watching heard the magic bust that's
doug brinkley's bus doug doug brinkley's
bus he's been a guest on book notes
about the great well that's a bunch of
kids you know as you know who travel
around the country and study
by actually doing it's an action class
and one of the things that astounded
these children was that the bus that the
um the school is so big and so one of
the physicalities one of the physical
problems of attending central high
school was not only that we were nine
among twenty five hundred it's at this
school was all these seven stories high
and two blocks long where are the little
black kids they are lost in the caverns
of this massive school so you had to
keep yourself together and so one day i
think was in march i went out the wrong
door i was supposed to meet the folks at
the other end i went out the wrong door
march of 58
58
i was standing out there and it was uh
snowing was it been snowing it was cold
very cold friday and i was just tired
just numb just absolutely jaded with
this whole experience and just you know
try living in a dream world keeping my
mind close folding my arms trying to
find some semblance of warmth there's
still just nine black children they're
still just nine by now they're eight
one's kicked out for uh the soup
incident
and uh which is what
well just before christmas of 1957
we were in the cafeteria and my
colleague minnie jean brown loves chili
and she had been knocked around
terrifically she
little by little her hope had been
depleted she had such hope that she
could sing on stage we all had this hope
i you know i i wear the right dresses i
i comb my hair i read i'm cute i sing
they'll like me soon
and we all had this hope and if you
didn't translate that into the action of
a warrior if you didn't translate that
into i'm going to protect myself you'd
die there and minnie jean seemed not to
make the translation she seemed to keep
having the hope and so she was battered
a lot more
and in early in december just before we
were to leave to go home for christmas
vacation
she was in line getting her chili we
were trying to pretend it was normal
it's okay we're in this cafeteria there
are hundreds of white students in there
and we've got our little
place in the back of the room and there
are adults outside a few guards guarding
us still
but minnie jean comes down this line
she's got her soup on the tray and she's
walking back towards her seat and we see
her far in the distance because his
cafeteria is like half the size of
football field and we see her far and
away in the distance stopped and we see
boys on either side of her seated but
they're still jostling her and we see
them jostling back and forth
and we see her talking and
you know and i'm sick in my head she was
my dearest friend at the time and we're
just you know thinking oh my god you
know because the only four of us there
she does if we get into trouble we knew
we'd be you'll be killed or we've been
told if one of us gets trapped in this
cafeteria one of us gets trapped
anywhere don't go after that person
don't help that person
so minnie jean is trapped i can't go get
her i can't help her ernie's there we're
sitting there ernie green earnest green
one of the other nine and um
all of a sudden we just see this this
this chili come off her tray and go
yeah down this this other kid you know
just grease
and uh the black cooks behind the
counter applauded and it's like dead
silence in there
and i'm thinking that's it you know i'm
gonna die right here today because
there's too many of them and too few of
us and i look around there's no adults
there and what are we going to do you
know but we got out of there we got mini
jean out of there
ninjin got out there and but it led
eventually to her that one incident
would lead to a series of incidents
you know
one down and eight to go by then by her
response
whether by accident or on purpose she
now showed a vulnerability and the
segregationist realized the way to get
these kids out of here is to provoke him
is to make him do something so her her
leaving her having to leave set us up
with a real dilemma
but so by the time i met link she was
already gone so i'd seen her
go she went to new york
to uh school dr kenneth clark
invited her dr kennedy clark the black
psychologist who had been instrumental
in the the brown decision invited her to
come to his home to go to a high school
called new lincoln and you know we put
her on a on a plane and you know we
watched her get all these new clothes
and go away and do just what we wanted
to do go away
by that time by christmas time
more than i wanted
anything i want to go away i want to die
i want to get anything to get out there
go back before we talk about length to a
moment just if you were when you go to
school every day what was the atmosphere
were there police or their troops or are
there hall guards or anything like that
well you know
by the second time we went to school
because of the enormity of the mobs
and the steady collection of the mobs
president eisenhower sent the now famous
101st airborne division
the the the korean war heroes the
the the men who had been sent to battle
the enemy were now guarding us personal
bodyguards and i write a lot about my
own personal bodyguard whom i call danny
who's not his real name no
originally the original manuscripts have
his real name i decided you know i am
told by another 101st trooper who is
here marty salmon who lives in san
francisco who calls me a renowned that
probably uh the guy is dead he probably
died later in vietnam but again he's a
kentuckian a southerner i don't want to
put him in jeopardy it was awfully nice
to me saved the quality of my sight if
not my sight when people put acid in my
eyes talk to me talk to me about my
posture
talk to me about
my beingness and so i don't want to do
anything to jeopardize it how did they
try to put acid in your eyes
gun water gun just walk up bang shoot in
my eyes and it was such an astounding
thing because the pain was so
overwhelming i didn't know what to do
and he just grabbed my wrist and jammed
my head underneath the water fountain
and and and i was just screaming because
pain was so searing i couldn't think i
couldn't i couldn't do anything
and when i finally got to a doctor the
doctor said he saved the quality of your
sight not your sight because he just
kept watching kept watching kept washing
it and you know he'd say shut up and
just you know stay here and and and so i
owe this man a lot i don't want to do
anything to hurt him and what was his
assignment
to be by yourself personal bodyguard and
and when would you when would you pick
him up
when would he pick you up as you get to
the school as we got as i walked across
the threshold the front door and how
long where would he be all day with me
not in classroom he'd stay outside the
classroom but he trailed me you had
personal bodyguards in the in the in
your immediate perimeter and then
distant ones and he he was like the one
closest to me responsible for me what
was it like in the classroom
hell a living hell
uh somebody walked past you and dropped
uh maybe a lighted piece of note paper
in your lap and then somebody else can
pour water on you most of the teachers
by
the say second or third week were in
school
were even those who were most rational
were by then harassed by segregationists
into ignoring what happened to us there
was one teacher i need to say her name
mrs pickwick the tiniest little thing
in in shorthand class who allowed no
messing around she'd say sit here melba
anybody touch her you go to the office
so there was like a kind of oasis in my
life and there uh you know mrs huckabee
who was the assistant principal vice
principal for girls
was to become our liaison was to become
what whatever benevolence existed within
the hierarchy of that school came
through her
and she was as benevolent as she could
be i think within the circumstance
cast upon her head
how are your grades by the way
fair c d
we passed did you ever get a sense of
discrimination oh no question on the
grades no question no question about
that that isn't even an issue i mean
that was like you know my mother always
said in the instant my mother i love my
mother because you know as i said she's
still correcting my writers letters and
reading returning them to me but you
know no matter what was going on she'd
sit me down say study
you know no question but that the
quality of my work
disintegrated but
even at my worst i was a very very good
student and uh
we we had trying circumstances with that
i think was ernie green had had a
tremendous problem with it with one
teacher who was going to fail him
actually
uh for no reason because he could prove
that uh
that it was unfair go back to link
we keep trying to get the link started
link is a white boy who
reached out to me he
uh by accident one evening as i said i
was standing in the wrong place
and
earlier you know a couple of parents
couple of days before had come and the
police had stood by while snowballs with
rocks have been thrown at them so you go
out the wrong place stand the wrong
place be the wrong place you could die
and i was standing the wrong place this
evening this afternoon after school and
lincoln uh was was nearby
and the boy named andy who had been
chasing me throughout that year
threatening me with a knife threatening
to kill me was approaching me with a
with a gang with a group of boys who had
just taunted me the whole year
and they were coming up to me
just less than a block away
and
i was looking around frantically do i go
back into school i couldn't get back in
the school what am i going to do you
know and link said
melba take the keys to my car and get
out of here
you got to go or you're going to die
and i thought oh you know what's he
doing he's i'm going to get arrested
driving his car i mean it's can't be
benevolent white guy what are we talking
he said no i'm not kidding take my car
i'll call you take my car i'll get you
i'll get you i'll get the car back later
and so he saved my life that day and i
took the car i drove home my grandma
thought i was crazy and she rushed out
and covered the whole thing with sheets
you know safety pins and sheets thinking
you know who's going to see this car in
the neighborhood are you out of your
mind child driving some white boy's car
what's going to happen you know
so but he saved my life and he was
become a friend a colleague an ally for
the rest of that year he started the
rendezvous
yeah write notes to each other
rendezvous talk to each other on the
phone
uh you didn't trust him
not at all because i thought well what
link's going to do is get me in the
corner someplace and the clan
is going to get me and you know and and
by this time we knew that that white
kids were being trained to taunt us that
way children they were having classes
and how to taught us like heel walking
to this day walking up here i i have
pains in my right heels from people
walking on my heels during that period
it was a focused concentrated effort how
would they walk on your heels from the
back just come up behind you and walk on
your heels all day
think of what that feels like after a
couple of days it was it was just
incredible you know it was like you it's
like a pain you can't can't escape you
know and so uh i thought you know how
could he be nice and he told me who his
parents were that they were involved in
in the segregation efforts that his
father was uh and a vile segregationist
that he had grown up with a
with a black nanny more or less and he
actually took me at one point to see
this nanny but that that was a lot i
mean you write a lot about that going to
see the black now yes because um
that i think is why he could be open to
me because he really loved this woman
who had who who had raised the second
generation of his family and had now
been farmed out sick dying with no
social security no hospitalization no
nothing just you're sick leave go home
and link would take her money and food
with his allowance because he'd grown up
with her all of his life
and so he took me to visit her because
he wanted me to get a black doctor to go
and see her did you do it oh yeah yeah i
got my grandmother involved and
we got a doctor to go and see her and
she she died the day he graduated
this is probably a little bit out of
consciousness but eventually you meet a
man and marry him that's right
and then
but he's white that's right how did that
happen
um
he had on the uniform of my 101st card
he had on a soldier's uniform he was a
soldier he was an mp
and i think part of it was that
that he that that he made me feel
comfortable he was black belt in karate
where where'd you meet him san francisco
but also by that time my heart had been
opened up by my surrogate parents by dr
mrs george mccabe now the blue eyes and
the red hair that had meant death and
torture to me was my dad george
and and my mom george mccabe who took me
to school every morning who took me
swimming who
who had family holidays with me the very
first day i went to school
it was pops who brought me to school and
said i'm here to register my kid
i just saw him a couple of weeks ago and
had dinner i will see him probably this
weekend he and mom so
now the only actually close to me than
my own father because i never had you
know a real relationship with my own
father is he still a liability he's dead
he died quite a number of years ago but
george mccabe and carol mccabe would
become real parents in my life
and so they opened my heart they taught
me that the color of hatred is neither
black nor eye so by the time you know my
husband comes into my life
i'm no longer
totally
closed in terms of what i think or who i
think white people are
white white people are different people
to invite them they're just people who
happen to be white
now did you graduate from little rock
central no only ernie green at that time
graduated later carlotta walls would
would graduate i think jeff did but but
none of them you know after that year
governor fault has closed that school
and we spent a year i spent a year at
home watching soaps out waiting for the
school to open again and it was after
that year that i came to california how
did he get the justification to
to shut the school down he disclosed he
didn't need a justification he closed
him and it took the courts a year to
circumvent that it just closed all the
schools
so now in our own community we were
pariahs because our own black community
was by then being squeezed choked the
life was being choked out of no school
all the businesses closed down if you
were black maid in a white hotel you
were castigated if you were black made
in white homes as were many people
including my grandmother you were
castigated so
uh by then
the black people in our community were
suffering so badly that we were not
popular in either community so when did
you fly to santa rosa well um
my uncle who
passes for white i have a relative
passes for white and he's actually in
the clan he's a sheriff and we've been
hearing that the klu klux klan had ten
thousand dollars debt dead five thousand
alive on our heads
you say he's in the clan he passes for
right that's this is quite common you
don't mean the kkk yeah i mean he's a
sheriff he's now re probably now retired
uh but yes he's a relative who used to
come home maybe twice a year
and uh so he called up my mother and he
said you know because he's
in the circle and he called my mother
and he says you know they're gonna skin
her alive get her out of there get her
out of there today get her get her let
her go because my mother my mother's
idea was to keep me there have me go to
fellaini smith college have me just
continue living my life go back to the
black high school but but he called and
said no you got to get her out of there
and by then the naacp was soliciting
homes for us safe homes across the
country because we were in great
jeopardy because segregationists would
do whatever it took to keep us from
going back to that school they were
going to have no more integration of
central high school they'd tell us
they'd do what they needed and they were
very clear about that so i left got on a
plane came here got off at the san
francisco airport and i met by all these
white people and i'm thinking gosh
almighty you know this is the clan
they're going to take me away it's going
to be the end and only this year when my
dad mom in santa rosa gave a uh
a party for me did i learn why the black
people didn't get there because it was
the santa rosa and double acp both
blacks and whites because they got
separated so it's a funny story really
well what was the connection with santa
rosa in the first place well it was the
naacp the santa rosa and double acp that
sponsored my coming here so i get off at
the airport and all these white people
rush up to me and they say hi we're from
the santa rosa and double acp well i
think to myself you know i've never seen
any plaque in the way why didn't they
obviously and you're 17. yeah and i'm
frightened out of my wits and you know
but eventually they would take me to
live with george and carol mccabe
and i would be welcomed into this family
there are four other children
and i would be welcomed as another child
in this family treated with the kind of
equality
that you could not explain on paper
or talk to me about words but the
actions of the mccabes were what healed
my wounds and turned me around what year
did you how old were you when you got
married
what 19
20 earliest wednesday and you got
married where in san francisco actually
we know nevada i think it was
and how long were you married seven
years
but at some point
you and link talk
and this
it comes up that you married a white man
and he said but early on he had said why
couldn't i go out with him when he was
leaving for college he was coming to go
to a major eastern college he said
he said the clan has ten thousand dead
five thousand alive on your head come
with me you come with me to a northern
town i'll take care of you i'll protect
you and i said are you out of your mind
i don't date white men get out of here
you know yeah i'm not going to do that
and uh he had been up to then just been
my friend and um his sudden change
frightened me you know and i knew the
last time i saw him i'd like never see
him again but then he continued to call
me when i came here
and um when i got married he said
wow
you know you said you wouldn't even you
wouldn't even go out with me but you
married a woman so it's right it was
then that you know he stopped calling me
he was very very angry about that
did you ever have you ever had a
conversation with
any of the white students that were
hostile to you at little rock
since this all happened not really um
with the students with other students at
central high school
one among them a woman named robin who i
remember smiling at me in school and she
talks about how she was beat up with
rocks because of being nice to me you
see in the beginning there were some
children who tried to reach out a little
bit but as time progressed they were
beat up they were you know treated
terribly for any advances or any
attempts they made at befriending us
um i do have a friend who is writing a
friend an acquaintance a white woman
who's writing a book about the anger
there and she will come back here uh now
and then and say to me be careful
because their feelings are the same most
of them say if we had to do over again
we'd do just what we did over again
and she always warns me you know be
careful when you go to little rock
but you know i've gone there signing
books and what most people come up to me
and say is come here and i said what do
you want they say just tell me who link
is and i won't tell anybody or you know
they they talk to me very friendly or
and you know so little rock to me is
it's a pretty friendly place white
people are very friendly when i go there
you know very talkative very chit chatty
and of course my brother has remained
there and he's quite respected
you know so i mean i didn't i i go back
there quite frequently
what what's this all about do you think
what's the what's the reason
the the white person the southern white
or the northern white for that matter
has this attitude
well i believe um
it's an unknowingness if i don't know
you
and know who you are know your humanness
and it's a fear for you know it
when people who feel this way have a
fear for who they are they don't have
self-confidence about who they are and
their ability because after all are we
talking about financial threats we're
talking about an unwillingness to share
the wealth aren't we really see
segregation and integration are just
other words for we don't want to share
what we've got
you see what i mean it's my theory that
the crips in the bloods exist and this
whole this whole violent thing that we
face partially or a great part of that
is due to an unwillingness to bring
people into the mainstream and accept
them every christian every blood was
originally a third grader who felt not
accepted and so it's about
i eliminate you i don't have to share
with you
i i don't need to see you as an equal
because then i have to include you so
it's about a whole big huge umbrella
of
you know
where one's heart is not seeing your
humanness because
you your eyes are blue and mine are not
it is about my inability to perceive
that someone wonderful could look other
and be other than i am and so it's a
whole deep soul kind of thing
it's a whole spiritual kind of thing
where do you put race relations at today
i'm sad that we haven't come farther
happy that we've come as far as we have
i'm always torn because i'm a person who
likes to look at the glasses half full
hey i'm a lady who rode in the back of
the bus and tried hard to get into the
white lady's bathroom so i'm not going
to complain about the ability to go to
nordies and try on clothes all the
privileges that i have here that i
didn't have before on the other hand why
are we even discussing this why are we
integrating schools why is there a
school in florida talking about they're
going to segregate why are some black
people saying they're going to segregate
their schools because they haven't felt
enough good out of the inclusion so i'm
saying that this is even an issue today
is problematic to me we've solved a lot
of other issues in the world we don't
get this one solved we're not going to
survive because as the world stands in
my view
i need everybody
it might be the guy in the corner the
asian who's going to show me how to
survive the next earthquake who's going
to take my hand and pull me up out of
the flood who's going to show me how to
grow a crop i can eat when i don't have
anything see so for me
i i don't see it as working unless we
get this whole thing figured out what's
your business today
writing i hope to be my essential
business for the rest of my life and
public relations and marketing i still
have a public relations company called
media exposure i still get a real kick
out of helping people start new
businesses and promote them if you go
back to little rock and the central high
school today what's the population mix
about 60 percent 67 percent black under
siege in terms of gangs and the whole
violence that pervades the rest of the
world armed guards walking through the
school heartbreaking still
academically superior
a variety of people i was just back
there shooting a good gig with good
morning america a few months ago and was
heartened by the fact that the children
around me one was indian
one was filipino two were white two were
black
one was asian it was gorgeous i mean it
was like this this this rainbow of
humanity surrounding me holding my hand
talking to me about what it's like to go
to school there now when you uh when the
kids talk to you what do they ask you
what are the things they want to know
they can't envision
uh
discussions of what went on in the
hallways they they can't imagine the
harshness of what went on with us
they asked you know uh
how did we live through it
uh
why were the children so angry that
kinds of things you know the the kinds
of
the the human perception that one human
being can can treat another like we were
treated takes a while to assimilate it
takes a while it took me a while being
in the school see every day you sit
there and you think
gosh
that guy's going to hit me then the fist
comes in you hit you in the face or the
gut and you think okay well he did
it takes a while to to to realize that
that this is going to happen to you that
this kind of violence is going to go on
so they don't realize
it's hard for them to to believe and
understand what was the incident where
the fellow came up with a gun with the
ink in it
my my easter dress and uh
that was a favorite thing of just coming
up and completely spraying you see you
look at this gun somebody walks towards
you with a gun you think oh i'm gonna
die where's the bullet gonna hit fine
can i survive it can the ambulance get
here with bang bang and he completely
inks up my dress and this happened a lot
inks eggs fall smelling liquid every
imaginable in dignity
and uh yet at the end of every day my
grandmother would say to me something i
try to remember at the end of every day
i have
what was the blessing in this day
what was good about it
who smiled at you
what wonderful thing happened to you
today what did you learn
you say two of your original nine are
living in another country that's right
canada and the netherlands did you ever
talk to them about coming back they
didn't want to
they wanted to escape
the sting of what we endured do they get
any of this in those others not really
no different different rules different
different rules totally different roles
they have married whites have white
children half white children live in
mostly all white communities and the
judgment is a different call as gloria
ray callmark talks about the judgment
where she lives in the netherlands is
education money and she can certainly
meet that criteria
she's you know enormous executive uh
head of a publishing company doing her
thing there whereas here it would have
taken her a lot longer to do it how many
of the nine wrote books
i'm the only one this far anybody else
trying to write a book i believe early
on terry did try to write a book and
found it
untenable i think one of them did yeah i
found it very difficult he's a
psychotherapist a psychologist actually
and we talked about the the harshness of
the difficulty of it i must tell you
that you know it took an enormous toll
of my life enormous toll on my beingness
but when i hold that book in my hand i
have a large
um
copy of the cover on my wall at home and
i cannot tell you what it meant to me to
hold the book in my hand because the
pain is in the book now i can talk to
you about it i can walk away from it i
can leave it before i could not did you
have to leave anything out because of
space
yes and also because the first
manuscript was 800 pages long oh well
700 pages long wait about 8 pounds
and also because the author the editor
thought
that
the extent of the violence would really
turn the reader off and so we cut some
of it out what are the chances that
there will be a disney movie
there were three major companies bidding
on it
i don't know if i should say disney or
and and and it looks as though
we have will be signing contact with
disney what do you want the movie to
show
the the humanness of my family the
realness of my grandmother and my mother
that that black people are real people
not cardboard characters and and when
people leave i want them to have to be
inspired and to understand the enormity
this is why i wrote this book i want
people to understand the enormity
of mistreating another human being
the enormity the impact of that no
matter what the context of it
to assume that you ever have the right
to mistreat another human being
it's wrong you don't you don't have a
right to deflower that spirit you see so
that's why i wanted to write this book
because i believe if i put it on paper
people would understand why it's wrong
to do that who are the
the leaders in that period that you most
respect
in terms of thurgood marshall goody of
course was was to us who was this big
tone man who came down south who we
talked about freedom he'd lived it he
breathed that he he he told us it was
going to be okay you're going to walk
through this wally brent was another
attorney uh who helped us all the people
at the nycp of course mrs davis bates
was a local woman
who who who supported us our parents
were like soldiers you know they were
always there for us uh taking the brunt
of the pain each of them in their own
arenas
sustained themselves somehow my mother
of course fired as you know in the book
uh from her teaching job we almost lost
our foothold there and so our parents
are really heroes and heroines because
how painful i look at the the film and
eyes and the prize now i'm not certain i
could drive up to a mob and drop my kid
off to go to school i'm not sure where i
can do that i look at and i think to
myself this is crazy they actually drove
up open through and said goodbye
darlings have a good day and there's a
crowd there's a mob out there
your mother used the local newspaper to
get her job back yeah well you know she
was she actually you know was the
forerunner of my pr company i mean we
sat on we had to figure it out we were
doing everything we could
and and finally grandma and mother sat
down and they figured out that what they
had to do was they had to get they had
to let people know they had to get some
press they had to get the fact that she
was being fired and threatened she her
job was taken away not because she
wasn't a good teacher but because i was
in central high school
how long did you work for nbc
what six and a half seven years yeah
street reporter yeah yeah some anchoring
but mostly treat reporter here why did
you leave the business
well you know immediately afterwards i
was offered another job in l.a uh
because i had a baby a daughter who i
was watching grow up without my being
present
and i wanted to be with her
i almost went to med school as well but
i couldn't do that because i needed to
be with my daughter i need to be her
mother as a single parent and that's
when i started to start a business at
home and work at home and also because
after you do seven to eight years of
storage you really done most of them
and i knew i had to reconfigure my life
very grateful for that period it grew me
up being a news reporter took me from
being this little girl from little rock
and and made me the adult that i am
today was it was it was a school a
laboratory for me and i'm so grateful
for that period because it exposed me to
a world i neither knew nor understood it
was fabulous
here's what the cover of the book looks
like
warriors don't cry the title
melba patillo beals thank you very much
for joining us my pleasure
[Music]
uh
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes
program
please send five dollars to
c-span transcripts in care of tape
writer incorporated
post office box 885 lincolnshire
illinois
the zip code is 60069
here's